it comes with being honest and I just
think it's dishonest to say there's no
consequence for sleeping around and like
most men will be lined up to date you
even if you slept with a hundred people
like that's dishonest but I don't and I
think it's lying to a younger generation
of women when we should tell them to be
more pure and protect that most sleeping
around brings more abortions
right yes or no yeah right it brings
more debts amongst babies people killing
their babies it brings more sexual
transmitted diseases so like I was
saying is being for mothers single
mothers also like I said is it better
for society or not and and you're saying
that promiscuity or some people here are
saying promiscuity
it it doesn't matter but it does because
it affects Society it creates single
mothers it creates dead dead children
and it also it does and it creates uh
sexual transmitted diseases don't men
not putting condoms on like create
babies as well as women or like or women
not using them for or or women not using
the 41 forms of birth control that are
available to them
there's like too many options tonight if
a woman gets pregnant it's on her yeah
because you can also require that the
men you sleep with wear condoms you can
make that a requirement so I would say
it's like on the women if you get
pregnant it's like kind of your own
fault because I think I think as a woman
I do take it on myself because obviously
I don't want to get pregnant but I don't
think it's all in the woman I think it's
definitely 50 50. I I tell you I'll give
you my opinion wise I think it's on a
woman because
unless it's a grape situation you let
him inside you okay and you have
remember my body my choice right that's
what we're told so it's your body so
it's your choice to let a man inside you
right and you know the consequences of
letting a man inside you
yes or no right so so this so this man
could be Reckless it's just like this
home I if if we let somebody in the door
right now and they run in here and they
go crazy right that's on us because we
let them in we didn't vet them properly
before we let them in right so if you
didn't vet the person properly before
you let them in that's on you that's
what they're gonna say okay so if I
choose that I don't want to be on the
pill or all the other options and I
decide that I want you to wear a condom
and then you don't wear a condom is that
on me as well
what I'm saying is if you trust you
you're already having sex so there's
already a sense of trust between you
so obviously I don't know I'm just given
a random example if it is in the dark or
whatever
and you do it yeah
stealthing is like a minuscule
percentage of what happens during sex
and my question no I was more miles and
well no my question is like why didn't
you vet the guys better you're sleeping
with you shouldn't be sleeping with a
guy you don't trust why don't you vet
any of us I did I'm saying in this
particular example you did trust that
person and you have and so is also
he could he can lie so I might have felt
like I'd vetted him well enough to be in
that position but obviously you find out
later it's not the truth then what
percent do you feel like that is do you
feel like that's the majority
no not at all I was actually just asking
what your opinion was in that particular
scenario I think when when we have these
conversations what people generally tend
to do is try to bring the exceptions
more so than a rule and it's like
normally on this show we try to argue
the rule more so than the exception
because there's always going to be
there's always going to be exceptions to
things right so it's like okay
dogs bark some dogs have got something
wrong with their you know their their
boys they don't but generally dogs bark
do you know what I mean so it's like if
people keep arguing for the dogs that
don't bark it's like well dogs bark we
already know dogs bark well and I would
say I would still say it's on you
because you chose not to be on birth
control
like there's no women don't go on birth
control yeah there's 41 forms of birth
control so and if you don't want to do
that you can get married
I think it's actually the guy's fault if
the girl gets pregnant go for it because
no it's the guy's fault because I mean
the even the pull-up method alone is 97
effective when done right so unlike
unless you want to be paying child
support like you should get better that
and then the other thing is like guys
should always carry condoms you know I I
because you never know when you get
lucky right but but my thing is like I
can do everything right and a girl can
still steal it like the NBA issue
statements every year they need to do
everything right what he didn't do
everything right you should flush that
thing take it with you when you leave
yeah good point so I think yeah if I had
a son I would tell him hey if a girl
gets pregnant it's one million percent
you're full if I had a daughter I'd say
if you get pregnant it's one million
percent your fault and everybody that
whether a boy or girl it's 100 your
responsibility what happens in your life
I just I think it's more on the girl
because we have more power right we have
like we have more power than men do in
every instance and and if we get
pregnant we can still get an abortion
where men have no say in that and if the
child is born you can put it out for
adoption yeah that's on that's not a man
doesn't have a say a man doesn't have a
say in one whether or not and so I don't
know how you men generally has to say
but it just doesn't make any sense
because the way the law works
it's still going to be the guy's
responsibility as well like and the
girls both of them individually I'm not
saying as a man that we don't have
responsibility I'm not taking
responsibility of demand I'm saying
you've got to protect your womb you are
head of security for your own vagina
right because we know that push comes to
shove
you're left with a baby a guy could run
to he could dip out which is why girls
are more selective when choosing
Partners right traditionally right
exactly I'm saying that's why it's on
you because I'm not condoning men like
running away from their responsibilities
by the way but I'm saying worse comes to
worse it's on you girl
it's not on me I can depart so that's
why I said women have to now start
vetting the men that are coming inside
them it's a smart choice to that yeah
you know
yeah
she doesn't it looked like you wanted to
say a lot earlier yeah yeah go ahead
well no I'm just thinking like
so I I've got an ex-girlfriend's of mine
pregnant not just once like many many
times and every single time it's like
100 been my fault right I was like young
or drunk or just like being unsafe or I
trusted what the woman was telling me
one time uh I had a 1 8 stand in
Australia and she told me she was on
birth control turns out she was lying
right or had an ex-girlfriend who told
me she has a medical issue and she can't
get pregnant and you know she actually
got pregnant and every single one of
them got abortions but regardless it was
not just traumatic for me it was
traumatic for them obviously but in the
end it was completely my fault because I
was being young and dumb and Reckless
well I'm I'm going back to how many
women
my head is spinning I said but but
you've also just held yourself
accountable to all of that
I I don't think it's entirely my fault
you can say it's completely errors but
um
completely hold yourself accountable and
like all right yeah I don't not believe
in accountability like I think that's
great I just think at this point in time
like women have more power when it comes
to reproduction I agree and so that's
why because they're the only ones that
have worms
right exactly so be careful did you let
inside there
because I don't have a womb
and all the women here do right so if
all the women here have wounds they have
to be more careful because like I said
worse comes to worse you were saying you
got drunk and you had sex with this girl
but she let you inside her drunk and she
lied no she told me yeah and that's what
I'm saying like she had more power in
that situation because she got the pick
if she was on birth control or not and
then she was able to lie to you and
basically trick you it's true and so
like how can you say you had more power
in that situation I think you should
have known better she was a stranger
right like she was a complete stranger I
just met this girl right I don't
remember her name and so what so what
stopped what's stopping me from having
intercourse with the girl and saying
I've had a vasectomy nothing nothing so
like so that which completely shifts the
Power Balance because one is more
accessible than the other one is much
more accessible than the other 41 forms
of birth control you speak of yeah yeah
so that's more excessive that's more
accessible and you don't have to get
surgery to get it there are a lot of
side effects to birth control though
especially hormonal especially if you
kind of have predispositioned hormonal
imbalance it can cause a lot of negative
side effects even the non-hormonal ones
can cause like really like a lot of pain
like a lot of discomfort and that sort
of thing so the choice to not be on
birth control can actually like be
attribute the fact that there's a lot of
difficulties with being on birthday I
understand that and I'm not discounting
that like I think there's a lot of
reasons to not be on birth control but
my thing is like we have more power when
it comes to reproduction because even if
you do get pregnant who has the power to
get an abortion we do
and even even if we have the kid who is
the power to give it up for adoption we
do and even if even if we keep the kid
who has the power to get get a guy on
child support we do and then who who
also has the option to get married to
the guy and then leave and take half you
do
so like when it comes to reproduction we
just don't have power much power when it
comes to reproduction
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible